touch balls 69 wrote a question ask what
I can't imagine this part of it but one
way to solve this is uh you know we've
got to get rid of anonymity for this
it's like let me ask the question ask
Sam why he sucks was the question well
yeah one reason why I sucked was Twitter
that was uh and I I've since solved that
problem so I mean touch ball 69 69 yeah
Festival 69 should be happy that I I
suck a little bit less now that I'm off
Twitter I mean if I don't have to hear
from touch balls 69 on the regular the
fact that you have to
um see that
it probably can have a negative effect
just even in moderation just to see that
there is like for me the negative effect
is um slightly losing faith
in the underlying kindness of humanity
yeah that was for me yeah you can also
just reason your way out of it saying
that this is an enemy and this is kind
of fun and it's kind of just the the
[__] show of Twitter it's okay but it
does mentally affect you a little bit
like I don't read too much into that
kind of comment it's like it's just
that's just
uh trolling and it's you know I I get
what's I I get I understand the fun the
person is having on the other side of
that it's like okay though I do well I
do I don't I mean I don't behave that
way but I do and for all I know that
person could be you know 16 years old
right so it's like it could be awesome
to all to count for Elon I don't know
well yeah that's right yeah yeah
um no I'm pretty sure Elon would just
tweet that uh under his own name at this
point
um uh and but you love each other okay
so the do you think so speaking of which
now that Elon have has taken over
Twitter
uh is there something that he could do
to make this platform better
this Twitter and just social media in
general but because of the aggressive
nature of his Innovation that he's
pushing is there any way to make Twitter
a pleasant place for Sam Harris
um maybe like in the next time I don't
know I think I'm agnostic as to whether
or not he or anyone could make a social
media platform that really was healthy
so you're just observing yourself week
by week seeing the effect that's on your
mind and on how much you're actually
learning and growing as a person and it
was negative yeah and I also seeing the
negativity in other people's lives I
mean it's obvious I mean he's not gonna
he's not gonna admit it but I think it's
obviously negative for Elon right it's
just not it's
uh and that was one of the things that
you know you know when I was looking
into the fun house mirror I was also
seeing that the fun house mirror on his
side of Twitter and it was just even
more exaggerated it's like we when I
when I was asking myself why is he
spending his time this way
I then reflected on why why you know why
was I spending my time this way to a
lesser degree right and at a lesser
scale and Adolescent risk frankly right
and so
um
and it was just so it's not just Twitter
I mean it is this isn't part an internet
phenomenon it's like the the whole
Hunter Biden mess that you you um
sword explored that was based I mean it
was on I was on somebody's podcast but
that was based on a clip taken from that
podcast which was highly misleading as
to the the general shape of my remarks
on that podcast
even you know I I had to then do my own
podcast uh untangling all of that and
admitting that even even in the full
context I was not speaking especially
well and didn't say exactly what I
thought in a way that was would have
been recognizable to anyone you know
even someone with
not functioning by a uh the spirit of
Charity but but the clip was quite
distinct from the podcast itself the
reality is is that we're living in an
environment now where people are so lazy
and there's their their attention is so
fragmented
that they they only have time for Clips
99 of people will see a clip and we'll
assume
there's no relevant contacts I need to
understand what happened in that clip
right and
obviously the people who make those
clips know that right and they're doing
that doing it quite maliciously and in
this case the person who made that clip
and subsequent clips of other podcasts
was quite maliciously trying to engineer
you know some reputational immolation
for me
um
and
being signal boosted by Elon and other
prominent people who can't take the time
to watch anything other than a clip even
when it's their friend or someone who's
ostensibly their friend in that clip
right so it's a total failure an
understandable failure of ethics
that everyone is so short on time and
they're so [__] lazy that the and and
we now have these contacts in which we
react so quickly to things right like
Twitter is inviting an instantaneous
reaction to this clip
um that
it's um
it's just too tempting to just say
something and not know what you're even
commenting on and most of most of the
people who saw that clip
don't understand
what I what I actually think about any
of these issues and the irony is people
are going to find clips from this
conversation that are just as misleading
and they're going to export those and
then people are going to be dunking on
those clips and you know we're all
living and dying by clips now and it's
um
it's dysfunctional see I think it's
possible to create a platform I think we
will keep living on Clips but you know
when I saw that clip of you talking
about children and so on just knowing
that you have a sense of humor you just
went to a dark place in terms of humor
right so like I didn't even bother and
then I knew that the way Clips work is
that people will use it for virality's
sake but the giving giving a person
benefit of the doubt that's not even the
right term it's not like I was it's
really like interpreting it
the truth is you even need like I even
give
Trump the benefit of the doubt when I
see a clip of trump so because there are
famous clips of trump that are very
misleading as to what he was saying in
context and I've been honest about that
like the whole you know there were good
people on both sides Scandal around the
show his remarks after Charlottesville
the clip that got exported and got
promoted by everyone uh you know left of
center from Biden on down you know the
New York Times CNN there's nobody that
I'm aware of
who has
honestly uh you know apologized for what
they did with that clip that CL he did
not say what he seemed to be saying In
that clip about the Nazis at
Charlottesville right and I've always
been very clear about that uh so it's
just you know I I
even even people who I think
should be marginalized and people who
who
um
who should be defenestrated because they
really are terrible people who are doing
dangerous things and for bad reasons
I think we should be honest about what
they actually meant in context right and
and this this goes to anyone else we
might talk about you know who who's more
where the where the case is much more
confusing but yeah so
everyone's care it's just so direct and
then I'm sure we're gonna get to AI but
you know the prospect of being able to
manufacture Clips with AI and deep fakes
and that where it's going to be hard for
most people most of the time to even
figure out that the the whether they're
in the presence of something real
um
you know forget about being divorced
from Context there was no context uh
I mean that is a that's an a
misinformation apocalypse that is we are
right on the cusp of and you know it's
it's terrifying